bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo je
vais vous proposer aujourd'hui la
présentation d'un géoportail et pas des
moindres puisqu'il s'agit du géoportail
de la wallonie un outil super bien fait
qui nous sera très utile pour le cours
de géographie
je vous propose tout de suite le
générique génériques
[Musique]
à la fin de la vidéo je vous proposerai
un exemple d'utilisation de wallonne map
au cours de géographie et en
l'occurrence au cours de géographie de
quatrième année dans l'enseignement
libre en belgique pour accéder aux
géoportail de wallonie c'est très simple
il vous suffit simplement de posséder
une connexion internet vous tapez
wallonne maps sur google vous arrivez
directement à la page du géoportail et
je vous donne rendez vous tout de suite
sur l'ordinateur
voici donc la page d'accueil du
géoportail wallonne m'a alors ce qui est
tout d'abord à regarder c'est le fond de
carte en fait le fond de plans et là
vous avez la possibilité de changer le
fond de carte je désactive toujours
bâtiment parce que bâtiment ça va vous
donner quand on sera sur des échelles
plus grande des petits carrés rose un
peu partout c'est assez ça va ça pollue
vraiment l'image à mon sens donc ça on
va l'enlever
il faut savoir aussi qu ici vous pouvez
jouer avec la transparence donc là
vraiment avoir des superpositions de
couches et faire disparaître le fond de
carte pour faire ressortir la couche que
vous avez choisi justement parlons des
couches
elle se situe ici de vous allez accéder
au catalogue du géoportail une fois vous
cliquez sur le plus vous avez ici les
différents onglets qui permettent de
voir les différentes catégories dans
lesquelles sont regroupés les couches
nous allons travailler avec la géologie
donc nous allons chercher dans nature et
environnement vous avez différentes
thématiques qui vous sont proposés ne
sait le sol et le sous-sol
nous allons d'abord sélectionner la
carte géologique
je vais la désactiver alors si je veux
la faire disparaître mais la garder dans
ma sélection voyage en effet petit oeil
elle est toujours là je ne la rend pas
visible à chaque fois donc ça c'est la
première chose dont nous allons avoir
besoin et éventuellement pour vous
montrer que l'on peut utiliser
différentes couches je vais aller dans
données de base aller chercher des
données topographiques et ajouter par
exemple relief j'ai fait un petit peu
mon shopping vous auriez pu évidemment
aller chercher d'autres couches ou
pendant l'été beaucoup savoir que quand
il ya beaucoup de couches bon tout est
en ligne
ça va commencer à charger
votre navigateur ou j'utilise google
chrome avec dizaines de couches ça va
encore mais parfois voilà les blocs
parce qu'il ya trop d'informations qui
est bien que le géoportail sais que je
peux me déplacer sur différents
territoires mais aussi dans les
différentes échelles nous on va étudier
ici viroinval et plus particulièrement
vierves sur viroin alors pourquoi parce
que c'est une commune qui est assez
caractéristique en fait d'une région
géographique qui s'appelle laquelle
estienne fait vous avez le condroz et
puis vous êtes la femme elle est ensuite
au plus au sud vous avez cette
canadienne qui précède l'ardenne
si à vivre sur viroin ce qui est
intéressant je vais vous mettre aussi
une photo sur laquelle on a travaillé
voici la photo est donc vous voyez ici
que l'observateur le photographe se
trouve en hauteur donc c'est une vue en
plongée et donc l'observateur et suivre
un tiennent un tiennent ces collines
calcaires et d'ailleurs c'est de là que
vient le nom qu'a lestienne puisque call
viendrait de calcaire etienne détiennent
en fait de ces collines calcaires qu'on
trouve dans cette région là et donc le
photographe prend une vue en plongée sur
le village de vierves sur viroin alors à
l'avant-plan on va voir sur cette photo
graphic on est bien sur des pelouses
calcaires
on voit que l'herbe est très sèche un
petit bout qui dépasse la droite
l'herbe est très sèche c'est une pelouse
calcaire
par contre dans le fond de vallée on
voit de l'herbe vraiment très verte
alors que supposer que il fait beaucoup
plus humide dans le fond de vallée plus
loin on a des reliefs assez important il
s'agit de la forêt ardennaise et qui
repose sur des reliefs qui sont beaucoup
plus élevés que le tiennent sur lequel
se trouve le photographe
on a donc trois ensembles tiennent le
fond de vallée et le relief ardennais
ici le géoportail va nous permettre
d'analyser cette photographie sous un
autre angle et de comprendre finalement
le fondement géologique des activités
qui sont présentes sur le sol de la
commune de vierves sur viroin mais aussi
la végétation
je vais tout d'abord activer la carte
géologique et elle va vous paraître un
peu compliqué avec les incrustations n'y
a pas de problème vous pouvez visualiser
les différents types de roches ce qui
est intéressant voyez c'est que je
voir déjà joué par transparence et
essayer de comprendre ce qu'il ya un
lien entre la végétation et la géologie
et déjà que bon les a vus au moderne
évidemment sont situés au niveau de la
rivière
mais si on regarde bien regarder un
petit peu les couches au mot et vous
allez voir que la première en tout cas
ici celle ci correspond vraiment à une
zone boisée
d'accord on voit aussi que le cvn ici et
le cv eux correspondent eux aussi à une
zone boisée
par contre le vx m
et le est ce bien là on a le village et
on a nettement moins de forêts et
surtout le jour là vous avez la forêt
ardennaise donc ici on peut déjà
comprendre pas mal de choses des liens
entre la végétation et les différentes
couches géologiques alors en gros le
jaune ça va être le grès vx m&a ce ça va
être des schismes tout à fait agréable à
l'eau et donc on va comprendre que les
zones les plus humides seront à cet
endroit là on peut déjà faire pas mal de
liens entre la géologie et la végétation
et l'affectation des sols finalement été
très intéressant et polo demain c'est
qu'on a des instruments de mesure oui
ici je peux prendre le profils
altimétriques et faire une coupe de la
région
donc voilà je trace mon transept dont 85
c'est une droite qui va couper un blanc
parce qu'ici j'ai une vue au plan et qui
va me permettre de faire une coupe la
coupe apparaît directement ici sur
espace et voyez ce qui est très très
très bien c'est que dès que je déplace
mon curseur sur cette coupe
le point se déplace également sur le
transept
nous allons analyser la succession des
couches géologiques en lien avec le
relais les premières couches cd schiste
c'est relativement plat le relief
augmente on arrive sur les formations
calcaires informations de tromelin d'ici
notamment on redescend
regardez ici je suis j'ai monté au
niveau du relief du 106 mètres
d'altitude et je suis au plein milieu de
la couche cvn ce sont des grès or là on
peut déjà tirer une conclusion en fait
certaines roches résisteront mieux que
d'autres à l'érosion
on voit ici que le grès résiste beaucoup
mieux que le calcaire à l'érosion
dès que j'ai une couche devait mage et
le relief plus important par contre ici
vous voyez là c'est complètement un des
mandats tout a été creusé ce sont les
couches schisteuses le schiste
désistement 1 en érosion parce qu'en
fait l'hiver comme il est imperméable
l'eau ne rendent pas ils restent en
surface mélo va vraiment venir se loger
dans les interstices de schiste et dès
qu'il gèle la le schiste va exploser à
ce qu'on appelle la jenny fraction et
tous ces génies
finalement vont retourner au viroin et
puis plus tard dans les océans
ces quelques images qui ont été prises
vous montre l'importance de l'érosion de
ces schistes touchés on arrive au viroin
donc évidemment le verrons un dépose des
alluvions des allures modernes le relief
monte c'est tout à fait logique puisque
on est sur des couches degré et donc le
grès résiste nettement mieux à l'érosion
comment expliquer finalement cette
vallée du viroin par les différences
géologique qui vont amener une érosion
différentiel ça c'est le terme important
c'est l'évasion différentiel si on veut
analyser pour la coupe à partir du fond
de carte la zone la plus basse et c'est
le village qui est ici près d'arriver
alors vous pouvez noter qu la zone ici
et cultiver son deschamps ben oui un
repli donc c'est assez intéressant de
faire cette coupe aussi avec l'imagerie
satellite
cette vidéo est maintenant terminée je
vous souhaite un bon travail avec
wallonne maps et à très bientôt dans une
autre vidéo
[Musique]